well today you saw the leaders trying to  extend their lead nakamura trying to  beat Aronian played very risky chess and  in the end he was ground down and very  disgusted by the loss he had her own Ian  on the other hand it was quite pleased  with the result of this game so to see  such top players have divergent opinions  as with his humorous yeah yeah wow I  guess I was right in the other match up  world number one Magnus Carlsen needing  a win to take the lead push for over  five hours and finally defeated the US  Champion gata kamsky I did not play in  the best way possible at all at some  point I lost control but fortunately it  was enough be sure to join us for  exciting round 5 action as the  tournament leaders face off tomorrow  here live in st. Louis at one p.m.  Central or at st. Louis chess club com